hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
June
26th what's going on Hawaii
how's it going oh geez that's fantastic
good to you did you have a nice weekend
oh [__] guess what happened all Freckle
skin guess what happened oh
55 year old pasty [__] bald son of a
[__]
I threw out my [__] back
like you cannot believe and it's it's
not my lower back it's my the middle of
my back
and like once every year and a half this
[__] thing goes out and when it goes
out
I go I mean I go down
to the ground like it's [__] over and
then like I'm down on like all fours and
I can't even like move my leg to like
get it underneath my foot underneath me
to stand up again I almost have to do
like child's pose and all of this [__]
I originally
the first time I got the injury I still
remember it I was
imitating Tony Atlas the great wrestler
and his finishing move was he would pick
his opponent up he would military press
him up over his head so I was doing that
to my little brother and I was going to
body slam him onto our Floral Pattern
colored sofa
still remember where I was I still
remember the living room I still
remember the brown rug you know this was
left over 70s decor Earth Tones were big
I [__] picked him up and I got about
three quarters of the way like above my
head and it felt like between my
shoulders blades folded
words and it was the first time I went
oh
down to the ground I was probably 16
years old
when I did that and uh it never bothered
me
again for years and then it started
going out again you know what's funny uh
I did this stand-up special called walk
your way out and the day of that special
it went out on me and I was just like oh
my God I [__] knew it this is just
how this business is but I was able to
kind of stretch and I was all right for
the special but
anyways this morning holy [__]
um and I think it came from stretching
I've been doing all of this stretching
and all of this [__] because I'm I'm you
know doing the PT from my shoulders
I did the elliptical I don't know what
the [__] I did
but I woke up it was completely out
and I sort of rolled out of bed and I
was all right
a little bit but as I went to stand up
it was [__] killing me and then like
I was like all right I can't put my
jeans on I need some sweatpants and they
were in my luggage that was in the hotel
like closet and it was up on us and I
reached for it with one arm
my right arm and I went just to lift it
I didn't even lift it just to try to
lift it and the thing went out and I
just went I was nervous if people heard
it in the hall I just literally I went
and I [__]
I was [__] doubt and I'm out here by
myself and I'm [__] on the ground I'm
in pain and I'm also laughing because
I'm like the [__] am I gonna do here I
can't get off the floor I'm in my
underwears there right
oh my God so
I somehow got back to my feet after like
10 minutes
and I went over to the sink and somehow
grabbing onto the sink and and then
leaning backwards
brought all of this relief and I did
that uh like four or five times and I
was able to get upright
and then I just sort of walked around
the city and uh I met with a friend of
mine for some coffee
and she gave me some uh muscle relaxants
and then I was fine and uh
then we went over to uh
the seller because uh it was funny I'd
done new work the night before
with Dean and Josh Adam Meyers and uh
they were saying hey you're gonna do the
brunch show tomorrow you can do the
brunch show at uh at the cellar I mean I
said the bro I'm not doing a [__] new
Nursery in my world
brunch that's doing a nooner those
things are a nightmare and a nooner for
my generation a comedian I don't know
about the kids today but like a nooner
was you went up at like [__] 12 noon
one in the afternoon in a cafeteria at a
college and the kids had no idea there
was a show they didn't want a show they
were studying they were laughing with
their friends they were doing eating
whatever they were doing anything and
then you had to come up
like this [__] obnoxious [__] who
wasn't invited to the party that just
put a lampshade on his head and when I
tell you like I have bombed everywhere
you can bomb no bomb
was longer more lonelier
more frustrating or infuriating than
bombing
at 12 noon 1pm
at a [__] College because these kids
were just looking at you like you were
the biggest [__] jerk off and they
were right you were right and you would
just standing there just eating your
[__] balls and they're looking at you
like you're an [__] and the whole
time you're up there you're mad at your
college agent you're mad at yourself for
saying okay to it and then you're mad at
the [__] people at the college who
didn't [__] promote the show right so
I I have all of this
um post-traumatic stress disorder
for that [__]
so anyway
Keith Robinson text me
and he goes uh where you at stupid I
said um you know I'm getting coffee
with Maureen Maureen Town who books the
uh the [__] uh the Patrice O'Neal
benefit and she gave me these back drugs
and I said I'm gonna come over there
and I'm going to slap you right in the
[__] chops right so I'm going over
there
had coffee at my favorite place my
back's feeling a little better
I got a little [__] nub cigar to
smoke on the way over there it's the day
of the gay pride parade and I'm in the
East Village and the village looks the
way it used to look which it was a bunch
of freaks in a good way everybody
walking around crazy clothes hair and
all of this [__] and I was just like
this is the [__] New York that I
remember where it was just like I mean
it was just in a the greatest way like
every single kind of person you could
possibly
want to see it was [__] awesome and
uh
I was in a great mood because I had
three great shows
and I go over there
and Keith's there and Estes there and
everything they're like you want to go
up I said yeah [__] it I'll go up I went
up and it was like one of the best
crowds
uh of the week that I went up front and
I was thinking like why is this crowd so
great it makes no sense it's like in the
middle of the day it's just like well
they got the day off
and when the show's over they still got
the rest of the day so they were like
extra relaxed and it went up and
[Music]
um
as much fun as I had on all these other
shows it was almost like my favorite
show of the week so thank you to the
seller
Forget Me On
and then I got to eat brunch you know
I saw Rachel Feinstein and all my
friends and all this stuff I had a great
time and uh Dean was there
and uh it was kind of a great ending to
this run of dates
where last night I was in um
I was in Newark
it's so funny I thought I was playing
the because they go this is where the
New Jersey Devils play in my head they
were still in the Continental Airlines
Arena
right
um
I thought that I thought they were still
there I didn't had no [__] idea I
guess they've been in this arena for you
know almost 20 years the new one
so listen to this night
before I go over there I get it I get a
text
I'm dropping all kinds of names here I
apologize but it was an unbelievable
weekend I get a text from [__] dice
saying hey man he goes you're playing
out in Jersey I want to come and see the
show is that okay
and I was like [__] yeah come on over
you serious and he goes yeah man I want
to say I haven't seen you I goes I want
to see you do a full set so I said [__]
yeah
so me Dean and uh and Josh out of Myers
we head over from the city to go do the
show I [__] show up to the show
I just on that Red Sox broadcast and I
was talking about
how one of the umpires had all this
padding
and he looked like Lindy Ruff because
back in the day I remember Fred Cusick
talking about Lindy rough going one of
the Bruins gave him a cheap shot in in
Fred Cusick was such a homer for the
Bruins he was going like well you have
to hit him he's so well protected right
and I always thought that was hilarious
so
I use that as a reference
saying how Lindy uh you know where all
these I said the Empire looked like
Lindy Ruff and then
this hockey player retired hockey player
told me this funny story that he goes
you know what we used to call Lindy Ruff
and I said what and he said we used to
call him Lindy on the road rough at home
meaning he played Mo you know when he
went to your building it was hostile
whatever he played but he didn't go real
you know
he stayed within the board like
boundaries I guess and then when they
would get home you know he would have a
little more [__] you know
a little more snort you know he'd
[__] you know elbow yeah stick coming
up and all that drop the gloves or
whatever get the hometown crowd going
right
so I don't know if that guy he's the
coach of the devil so when I showed up I
had it they had a little they always
give you like a jersey and they put your
name on it so [__] cool and it was a
little card in there
and it said Welcome to our building
uh I hope it doesn't get too rough
tonight are you FF sign windy Ruff it is
now my favorite piece of memorabilia
I've ever gotten
um you know they like you got the Jersey
I was like [__] the Jersey do you got
the card I'm saving that I want that I
mean I took the Jersey too but I wanted
a card so
and then uh dice comes in this is like a
Make-a-Wish nice for me
and dice comes in
and the second I saw I'm a game of hug I
go dude you're going up tonight and he
goes oh no no it's one second no dude
you're [__] going up tonight he goes
you sure I go yeah
he's like ah [__] now I gotta figure out
what I'm gonna do so we just sat there
we're hanging out
you know
all these people the end of the tour
club soda Kenny and all that [__] and
you know
Josh goes up he kills Dean goes up he
kills
and then he uh club soda Kenny
you know back when dice first blew up
was his security guy and he used to
intro him like he introd him for all the
you know that HBO special he did at
Madison Square Garden right so Kenny got
to reintroduce him did the old school
intro
brings Dice Clay up there and dude when
I tell you like I saw this guy
before I was ever a comedian in November
I believe it was November 1989 I saw him
at the Worcester Central ice when I tell
you I was the second to last [__] row
all the way across the [__] Arena all
the way up top
and I saw him if you ever told me that I
was ever even gonna do stand up forget
about
you know start selling tickets forget
about ending up playing an arena and
that I would do it with him it was so
[__] surreal so dice goes up
and when he hasn't lost a step he went
up there it was just it was like I was
back in 1989 absolutely [__] murder
the only way I can compare it to is you
ever go to see a band that's been around
for 30 [__] years and you're thinking
like all right they're gonna tune down
or whatever and then you go out
and they they still playing it in the
same key and the singer is still [__]
killing it
and that was like watching dice like
literally
was killing so hard
I was like going [__] now I gotta follow
this
Place went nuts we brought him up and
then he closed with the nursery rhymes
and I literally had my arms up over the
head when he when he started doing the
thing with the cigarette and [__] all
that you know [__] in the head and all
that I was like oh my God
oh my God he's gonna do the nursery
rhymes and he just Hickory Dickory Dock
his chick was sucking my [__] right and
I was just like it was Unreal
and then he brought me up
it you know I almost got choked up I'm
not gonna lie to you I did I did get it
I did get choked up thank God my back
didn't go out and uh
I went up there and I [__] I got to
hug him great job and all of that and
then it just was amazing and then I did
my show the crowd was unbelievable the
sound was amazing
it was the it was the uh perfect night
um Bridgeport was unbelievable I got to
work with Vinnie brand
who does the stress Factory in New
Brunswick and Bridgeport he came up he
did five up front we had a [__]
amazing debate backstage
you know he's a club owner I'm a [__]
you know comedian and I'm like yeah
remember this date you [__] me on this
yeah he goes I never did that you you're
[__] delusional had this great debate
with him
um
saw him and Bill blumen write the great
promoter from Boston who did Fenway Park
with me I got to hang with them and then
the day before that I was in Hershey
and um
Pennsylvania and they were an
unbelievable crowd and I had like three
of the best shows in my career because I
figured out why I'm doing stand up again
you know I was kind of having this
existential crisis yes I did just say
that word and I finally know what the
[__] it means because what happened was
I I [__] took these mushrooms and I
went to therapy and I figured myself out
and I got happy and for once in my life
I didn't need to do stand-up
as far as like I used to live and die by
my sets like if I had a good set if you
guys laughed at me
it like healed me for 24 hours or
whatever it made me feel good about
myself if I went up and I bombed it made
me feel it reinforced how I felt about
myself so then I would like a [__]
drug addict I would have to the next
night I gotta I gotta have a I gotta
shake that one off I gotta have a good
set so I can feel whole again
so then what happened [__] 30 years
later I finally figured myself up a
couple of mushroom trips and some
therapy all of a sudden I'm happy and I
realized that like you know that rush I
get on stage is not
you know
the same thing is like having a home
life a wife you love kids that you love
and all of that and then all of a sudden
everything came into perspective and
then it was like why would I leave this
why would I go on the [__] road why
am I doing this now right so that was my
three shows in La when I did the Roxy
the Troubadour and the Roxy I was you
know having a good time and have a good
sets but I was [__] floating when I
was up there
I'm like why am I still doing this
I feel like I'm cured and then what I
figured out
I figured it out on the last night it's
like wait a minute bill so basically for
30 years you've been doing it for
yourself
selfishly
how about now you go out there and you
do it for them they're coming they had a
tough week they got depression or
they're just [__] their boss is an
[__] or whatever they watch the news
they're bummed out they need a laugh go
up there and be this
Dancing Clown and just do it for them
and then it took all this pressure off
of me I was like oh yeah
why don't I not be a self-involved
[__] [__]
and it changed my energy and then like I
wasn't going on stage defensively and I
had I had like these really like I felt
light on stage except the Newark one
going on after dice I was like oh my God
oh my God [__] dice Jesus Christ so I
have a whole new perspective
um
I don't know and now I'll probably get
[__] for that I liked him when he was
[__] angry
um no I had all kinds of new [__] came
out this week so I'm very excited about
that so thank you to everybody that came
out
um
and uh yeah and that's it that's the end
of this thing but the next two weeks I'm
also on the road and uh I think I got
Allentown next
I have no [__] idea but um
I don't know
I don't know can get home hang out with
my wife and kids I also made this
promise like you know when I'm not on
the road working which I have to do as
the dad
I'm just making sure every single day
I do something with my kids
um
you know some sort of like
event now you know take them somewhere
or play with them or do something like
that because uh
you know you get busy I always I always
hang with them at the end of the day
like the last like
you know two and a half hours which is a
lot of time compared to what you know
the way I grew up but uh I still feel
like you got to do like that uh
you know
go play with them outside and if they're
like absolutely hilarious now so
um
I don't know my [__] back Jesus
Christ I was going to do the elliptical
every single day right because my wife
bought me this beautiful goddamn shirt
this green shirt buttoned down that's
the same color as like you know that
British racing grain
and uh she bought me this [__] thing
right before
I hosted SNL
in 2020. and I've never been able to fit
it
and I still can't
um
so I gotta start doing some cardio
that's like my thing I watch that
[__] Arnold Schwarzenegger
um documentary on Netflix where he's
just like I would get this thing in my
mind and I get this vision of how I
wanted to look and if I could see it I
could be attendant you will your body to
do what it is that you're seeing in your
head whatever the [__] he said I was
just I was like it was like a great
coach giving you a pregame speech and
then you want to go out and go run
through a brick wall so that's what I
tried to do and you know what happened I
[__] threw my goddamn back out
oh
oh my God I just sat up it's all right
I'm gonna get through this I will get
through this whenever I have a [__]
back problem you know it's funny that my
[__] uh
my hotel room I got all these goddamn
ants in here you know when they come up
through the drain in the sink right
so the lovely Nia keeps going and she
goes why don't you [__] switch rooms
and I'm like because I'm not talking to
these people
I would rather I went to a hardware
store
I get it right here I bought I bought
raid aunt and Roach
because I know the people you know you
know you call them oh yes sir will be
well and problem oh James Louise you
know they act like it never happens it's
like dude I get it it's New York I'm
just happy there's not a bunch of
roaches [__] crawling all over me and
they're like well send a guy right up
you know 40 minutes later they're not
there so I go all right [__] this I'll
go out and get some coffee
and I'm just gonna go uh
I'll stop by a hardware store and I got
the The Raid ant roach but these [__]
things over these are like New York City
ants so it takes a little more than a
little bit of poison to stop these
[__]
so I stayed out late last night like an
[__] right and uh earlier this
morning I was having this dream
that I was sweating and this drop of
sweat was rolling down my forehead and
then I kind of woke up and I realized it
was an ant
so I like freaked out because I thought
my bed was all covered in ants you know
you [__] just waking up I was like I
was thrashing around I think that that's
what kind of put my back over the
[__] top
uh
so anyway
I I you know I woke up this morning and
I actually looked at the floor and there
was so many [__] ants do you remember
that in the Raiders Raiders of the Lost
Ark when he looked down that [__]
that hole and he's like why is the floor
moving and he looked down and it was all
a bunch of snakes
um
that it was the ant version it wasn't
that bad but that's the first thing I
thought of which by the way that scene
never made any sense it's like okay all
of those snakes are down there it was an
amazing visual [__] thing
and you know back then they couldn't
green screen it so they had probably had
all of those goddamn snakes but it's
just like well what the [__] are they
eating
they'd have to be a whole bunch of mice
and rats down there unless they'd be
eating each other right all these
different kinds of species and [__]
um I [__] hate snakes I I mean I love
watching shows about them and all the
stuff they do but like I really feel
like they set up the rodents
you know in all of those things because
somehow it's like they show the snake
and then they cut to the mouse
it's like how the [__] do you know he's
going after that Mouse
you know what I mean like I I never
understood why Peta never calls them up
you know you can't [__] walk around
with the goddamn Fox around your neck
but these [__] I saw a video one time
they're showing the [__] snake then
I'm Underground
camera looking at a [__] Mouse in the
ground it's like how did you know he's
gonna go down that hole how'd you get a
[__]
a a [__] camera down there it was a
total setup
and then they're just filming the
[__] thing going in there they got
all this you know they scored the thing
it was like watching a a [__] action
movie
sorry I had to drink the last of that um
I don't know
did I mention to you guys I want to see
that horror movie smile
I didn't have the right headphones but I
I was watching it with no sound
and I just really liked the way it was
shot
and uh the first woman
in it that plays the first crazy person
I just thought she was amazing
uh
in it and I usually I usually do not
like [__] horror movies
they [__] scared the [__] out of me
but like I mean I was actually talking
to somebody about horror movies in the
80s where they were so [__] scary and
then they just
like overnight
it just got silly it was kind of like
the [__] metal scene that I that I
was watching like in the early 80s right
up to about [__] 83 84.
it was [__] killer
you know and then it just started
spinning out of control
how how big the hair was the amount of
makeup and then guys literally wearing
like pink and all of that I mean you
think the gay pride parade is got a
whole variety of people they had nothing
I'm on Glam matter well I couldn't say
nothing but I mean actually it probably
came from that scene
um
it just became yeah it just became like
this this crazy
it was like s m [__] pink guys with
lipstick on it was [__] it was it was
it was actually inadvertent like
accidentally Progressive
while they were just singing about
banging chicks and [__] objectify him
and and the devil and all that it was
[__] bizarre right and I feel like
like horror movies were the same way
where like
um the level that they had gotten to
in like the 70s with like the Exorcist
and uh Halloween and all of that kind of
like then opened the door to going into
the 80s and that first [__] Friday
the 13th
okay don't okay don't listen this
because it's totally I'm totally gonna
ruin the [__] movie if you never saw
it all right but it was also the movie's
40 years old
so in that first one
you know that was the basically the back
story was
a kid drowned up at Crystal Lake a kid
named Jason
Voorhees or whatever his name was Jason
right
and
basically the mom
felt the camp counselors
should have been paying more attention
but they were too busy partying and
[__] around and all of that type of
stuff so in the first one
you know all of these people are getting
killed and you're just assuming it's a
guy and then in the end it turns out
that it's the mom
I forget what happens to her I imagine
they ended up killing her
and then in the end of the movie I'm
totally ruining the movie but I'm
telling he's [__] 40 years old
this [__] scared the [__] out of me
like nothing I ever watched somebody was
on a boat out in Crystal Lake
where Jason died and then and they were
playing this calm music it was the end
and I was so relieved that the [__]
murderer was done and you thought the
movie was over this is the first time I
ever saw a movie do this it was that
last scare and I had no idea it was
coming
and when that [__] came up the
drowned Jason came up and grabbed the
person in the boat and pulled them out
under and they did it like
super fast and then into slow motion I
think I I [__] literally pulled my
legs up one of the I forget how old I
was when I saw 13 or 14. I was like
and also you gotta understand like I
never seen movies like that my parents
didn't take me to that and all we had we
had like three [__] networks in our
UHF thing was busted so you know I was
watching like the [__] I went from
like the Mike Douglas show in cartoons
on Saturday morning to the first Friday
the 13th it scared the [__] [__] out
of me and the movies were good and then
when they brought Jason in with the you
know the first one he had the second one
he had the [__] up face the third one
he got the hockey mask and somewhere
around the third one
it just started becoming like
you know just slasher movies
where it was just like you know seeing
somebody get their arm hacked off and
blah blah but they weren't building
suspense and everyone was just getting
gutted and then I remembered I would go
to the movies to see him
and it went from people being scared in
the early 80s to in the mid by the mid
80s people would go to slasher movies
and would be screaming with laughter and
yelling and [__] around you'd still
jump but everyone would laugh
somebody's eye would get popped out or
get their head slashed and people be
like ah and they would just
you know like they were watching a
hockey game and somebody got like
checked and they kind of like uh
they got stupid
and it wasn't good you know like any any
form of Music where it just gets blown
out it just gets dumb and then something
new comes along and then it gets good
again right and I feel like horror
movies did that and now
I don't know somewhere around the Blair
Witch I was just like you know what [__]
this [__]
[__] these horror movies like these
people are going Beyond trying to scare
me they're trying to psychologically
scar me
for the rest of my life
I don't want to watch this [__] and uh I
think the last ones I watched
uh
I think
I saw old boy and I saw the audition and
Bobby Lee told me to watch both of those
and I was just like you know what this
is just getting [__]
you know and I started to watch like saw
and I'm just like I can't I can't handle
I don't know how you guys watch those
[__] movies like those things like
really [__] me up so anyway I probably
haven't sat down
the last one I saw was that babadook one
and I couldn't get through it
was a mom there was [__] kids and I'm
just and a kid I'm just like [__] this
like it was so freaking me out I was
actually angry at the movie I'm like I'm
not [__] watching I'm not putting
myself through this and then I just sort
of swore off of them
and then the other day I saw that when I
was like I don't know I might have to go
back I might watch that one with Nia
um anyway and with that let me um
let me get to uh the the ad reads here
for the week where the [__] am I here
all right here we go oh I forgot to say
there's a new show added for Wednesday
October 4th University Park Pennsylvania
at the Bryce Jordan Center pre-sale
starts on Wednesday with the code Burr
b-u-r-r on sale Friday to the public
um all right and with that we got two
reads oh look who it is everybody it's
policy genius
talk about why life insurance is
important oh I can do that I can do that
because I have a number of
people that I know that had were married
with kids
that suddenly died and didn't have any
life insurance and then you know
it just what the people are left with
you got to make sure you got to make
sure people are going to be okay
um if you if you die
if you have a wife and kids I mean you
got to make sure they're gonna be okay
all right
um
all right if you have a family like I do
you know how much your loved ones depend
on you in a worst case scenario you
wouldn't want them to worry about money
meaning if you die policy genius was
built to modernize the life insurance
industry their technology makes it easy
to compare life insurance quotes from
America's Top insurers and just a few
clicks to find your lowest price with
policy genius you can find life
insurance policies that start at just 25
per month for one million dollars worth
of coverage some options offer coverage
in as little as a week and avoid
unnecessary medical exams policy genius
has licensed award-winning agents who
can help you find the best fit for your
needs they work for you not the com not
the insurance company that means they
don't have an incentive to recommend one
insurer over another so you can trust
their guidance policy Geniuses for
parents caregivers anyone else
who has people who depend on them they
simplify the process of getting life
insurance so you can protect the people
you love there are no added fees and
your personal details are private no
wonder they have thousands of five-star
reviews on Google and trustpilot your
loved ones deserve a financial safety
net you deserve a smarter way to find
and buy it head to policygenius.com or
click the link in the description to get
your free life insurance quotes and see
how much you could save that's
policygenius.com
uh
um all right ag1 all right
where are we going where are we going
all right he1 our new partner our next
partner is a G1 uh Alpha Gulf one the
daily foundational nutritional
supplement that supports the whole body
health
all right I drink it literally every day
uh
um easy routine I'm always looking for
Life upgrades which is why I've come to
love and Trust ag1 why take a bunch of
different things when you can just mix
one scoop of powder in water once a day
ag1 was designed with ease in mind so
you can live healthier and better
without having to complicate your
routine ag1 replaces your multivitamin
probiotic and More in one simple
drinkable habit you know when they put
the shampoo in the conditioner in the
same bottle this is what they're doing
here high quality he1 is a foundational
nutritional supplement that delivers
comprehensive nutrients to support the
whole body Health Science driven
formulation of vitamins probiotics and
Whole Food Source nutrients every scoop
just is packed with 75 vitamins minerals
antibiotics and Whole Food sourced
ingredients of high quality that gives
me major benefits like gut and mood
support boosted energy and even
healthier looking skin hair I don't know
about that for me but you guys will and
nails ag-1 is raising the standard for
quality in the supplement category
um he1 helps you build your first Health
Foundation delivery plus travel packs
you just mix the powder uh into ice cold
water and drink it first thing in the
morning that's it it's as easy as that
with ag-1 you're taking good care of
your body each day it's really that
simple
um if you want to take your own if you
want to take ownership of your health
try ag1 and get a free one-year supply
of vitamin D and five free ag1 travel
packs with your first purchase go to
drinkag1.com that's drink ag1.com to
check it out all right that's it that's
it for the reads okay
what do we got now it says Bill we have
some great
um
we've got some great reads here what the
[__] did I do um
um I guess where the [__] is it
oh there it is there it is there it is
let's see here
um all right
here all right greetings from Greece
oh would you look at this dear Billy the
great I cannot wait to see you in Athens
in September I hope you have some time
to see our beautiful country I think
you'd love the lifestyle here the food
and history are amazing have you ever
thought of retiring in Europe
uh absolutely I have
I have but you know what I would Miss
America
um I would
I mean I'm like everybody I love my
country I love where I live and I would
miss the uh I'd miss the sports
I like it I but I I would like
you know I visit other continents
and I like them and I have a good time
but I'm not not gonna lie to you after
like 10 days
I do you know
I do Miss America so
um
I don't know I've thought about you know
you know all that dumb [__] you think
about you know maybe I could just
[__] be in Spain or France or
whatever and blah blah blah but I I
would uh
or Italy I would miss it and then also
you know if I lived if I was like uh an
immigrant I'd get treated like one after
a while you guys would be like you know
hey you guys don't mind people visit you
stay there like what the [__] are you
doing here taking our God damn jobs
um
but if I did
I don't know
I do think of retiring but then I don't
know what I do with myself but I also
wonder like what um
where I would retire
I don't know what I'm gonna do
whenever I ever think about retiring I
always have a small house
with no neighbors and I'm just [__]
hanging out
and I live a simple life I don't I
wouldn't want to have no neighbors I
would like to live in like a simple
[Laughter]
town you know a nice downtown area cool
[__] people good mix of people and uh
you know just putzing around town with
my wife that's that's all I would want
but um
I don't know how do you just like how do
how would I retire in Europe I'm not a
citizen
how would they allow me I wouldn't even
know how to do that
um
I don't know I did see uh
you know there's a couple people I've
been fans of that like
just live in France or something like
that
maybe I would do that and then finally
get the language down because I'll tell
you the other day I was uh you know I've
been listening to like
they got this app where you can like
listen to French news slowly
and uh I couldn't believe how much I
kind of knew what they were talking
about and that was exciting because I've
been really bad about my studies for
like the last three months I got really
frustrated with the future tense and
then I got busy with other stuff so I
have to get back on and I was using
Pimsleur and now I'm thinking you know
what I'm going to read some books and
I'm gonna just watch the news every day
it seems like that's easier
that's where my brain is right now and
then I'll get back to the pimsler thing
but um
I don't I don't know I I I do enjoy
travel but to answer your question I
don't think I could retire over there I
am an American through and through
um so I would probably be I would stay
here all right your new bed
oh Jesus oh Jesus I was talking about
how my wife bought a Craftmatic
automatic adjustable bed
and uh
you know we gotta I gotta figure out you
know
when she puts the vibrating thing on and
I don't have it on it's like vibrating
still vibrating my side of the bed and
if I sleep on my side and my head my
ears on the pillow it sounds like
somebody's drilling for oil next to me
anyways the person says hey Billy Fritos
I just heard and enjoyed your most
recent podcast we talked about your new
Craftmatic Adjustable bed uh we have had
one of those for years let me clue you
in on a secret about those beds the
raising and lowering of the head and
feet is amazing so amazing that if you
raise both the head and the feet up as
high as they can go the bed will fold
you up to the point where you can
practically lick your own
love your stuff uh keep the vibe alive
um
yeah I I don't know but I I just know
that she loves it and uh
oh man I remember this comedian Paul and
their dizzy used to do a [__]
hilarious bit about
that bed
um and I'm kind of living that right now
uh
I don't know we got the thing and then I
went on the road so I'll I'll see if I
learn to like it I I find that the most
comfortable I find is just having just
laying down normal in it so we shall see
anyway uh how do ladies always win hey
there Bill uh not really looking for
advice but this interaction seems likely
to get you all fired up
my daughter High School junior got in to
a summer program where she'll live on a
college campus for five weeks and attend
college level classes
um
upon completion she will be eligible for
free four-year College ride anywhere in
the state
well that's a pretty good deal
um so I'm a super so I'm super a super
proud dad several thousand students
apply only a handful make it okay so the
wife drives are out there I had to work
on drop off day woke up early with them
packed the car said goodbye Etc get a
call from my wife a bit later the wife
says honey you really should have come
pauses here my internal monologue [__] I
should have taken the day off work to
make the drive with my little girl [__]
that I miss a transitional life moment
wife continues first sentence she says
she packed too much [__] the elevators
were crowded we had to carry stuff up
some stairs we really could have used
you me wow I kind of thought you were
talking you were taking that a different
way I didn't expect to say you to say I
should have come just to be a pack mule
wife oh I mean it is emotional but no I
meant that she just had five weeks of
[__] and it was hard for us anyway we oh
God anyway we hung up
ten minutes later I get a text from her
do you need me to tell you when it's
appropriate to support your child
oh brother
she flipped that around on you huh being
a 25-year vet in first ballot Hall of
Fame inductee in this relationship I
didn't respond
just mark the text as read and on went
on with my day that's great
silence let her think about what she
said and then you're not engaging so all
she's left with is the last thing that
was said which is what she said
fantastic
so far you are absolutely crushing this
um and I am believing that if I read the
rest of this you're going to uh win this
[__] argument
so here we go continuing on
um
uh but what the [__] damn it must be
nice to get to go through life always
being right and putting me in a box
where I'm a physical resource to be used
at her disposal can you imagine if we
treated them like an object
well we do we go look at them [__]
titties anyway I suppose that is how
women historically have been treated but
Jesus [__] Christmas
uh this new [__] seems like a bit of an
over correction I very much like
assuming you read this on the MMP that
the lovely Nia is on uh love when you
two go back and forth mostly when you
admit she is winning the ball breaking
anyway stay out of the Sun
you [__] go [__] yourself
um
yeah well I would have just said to her
I would have written back just said well
just so you know
I was at work
like beating myself up
thinking like man I should have taken
the day off I missed this whole thing
but like I just feel my job as a man is
to go out and work and provide
and I what I was hoping was you were
going to say you dropped her off and she
was okay and she didn't cry that's what
I needed and when you said I wished you
were there I thought you were talking
about that and instead you brought up
you know her five weeks worth of stuff
and it just made me feel like
that's how you viewed me
you just say it like that rather than
being like what am I some sort of pack
mule you [__] [__]
which is really what you want to say but
um
that's just gonna lead to you know
fighting
um
yeah but that's I I you know
that is a part of it
it really is a part of it like you know
and they're sort of allowed to objectify
you as you are something to pick up
heavy [__] but you can't objectify them
where you're just like hey I got [__]
needs over here and they can be like ah
yeah I'm not in the mood all right I see
that well you know I'm not in the mood
to pick that [__] up that you could pick
up too
why do I always have to pick it up
um but you know I can be honest you know
the deal as a 25-year vet that's not
going to get you anywhere it's not you
know you're just going to piss him off
and then your life is going to suck so
um great move not responding
I condone that it's just stupid
[__] die on another Hill all right
phrases
hey Silly Billy gumdrops I had a family
in town
I had family in town I had the family
bag East and we were talking uh we were
taking talking about how much people
can't stand criticism anymore and my
aunt said yeah
I told them I'm not going to buttercoat
it oh Jesus Christ I laughed and asked
her if she says buttercoat instead of
sugarcoat because she's a diabetic she
said she's been trying she's been saying
that forever I never heard sugarcoat
side question do you ever find yourself
playing the kick drum with your left
foot while driving thanks yes I do
everyone else can go [__] themselves and
you have a nice day
um all right let's back up for a second
I forget if I told you this one I had a
friend of mine
she was talking about her dad going oh
yeah you know my dad
she goes uh
she said oh she said you know we had a
temper
she said swore like a fish
I just started cracking up I go
I think it's it swears like a sailor and
drinks like a fish you combine the two
and then she laughed going like I always
[__] do that there was so many people
that do that you either get them wrong
or my favorite is the amalgam when you
come ah the guy the guy swears like a
fish
you know
he drinks like his drinks like a sailor
still works I don't know but I like that
one I'm not gonna butter coat it
I'm not going to sugarcoat it
frothing at the bit chopping at the bit
frothing at the mouth
um all right incorrect phrases uh hello
how are you bald head Billy
uh my buddy and I were having beers and
playing pool at a bar and we overheard
this drunk kid with his friends say
don't worry bro it's water under the
fridge
oh my God
which can happen though you can't get
water under the fridge
um my friend and I immediately looked at
ourselves and started pissing ourselves
laughing water under the fridge that is
[__] Epic
oh that's amazing
his friend tried telling him he had it
wrong but he insisted no man when you
drop an ice cube and it slides under the
fridge you can't get it so you'll have
water under the fridge
you forget about it and move on
oh my God that is amazing from this
Canadian kindly go [__] yourself please
and thank you
water under the fridge everybody
that is the that is my latest
favorite one
um all right anyway I am here in uh
staying downtown in the East Village and
uh
what a great [__] day man it really
these last couple times I came to New
York really made me miss New York and uh
and this is a cool generation of young
people
uh good looking generation God damn it
you know I'm at that age I walk down the
street I just look at people just going
like [__] I wish I was that skinny
I'd kill to have that guy's stomach I
literally do that I'll see somebody do
something like [__] I wish I could do
that with my shoulders
um
and I am like I don't know how it
happened I am just an old man now and
I'm sitting here like 30 years older
than these people
and they get all of this technology and
all of this [__] and I am just sitting
there drinking a cup of coffee reading a
newspaper and I actually get people my
age going like is that a [__] noose
nobody reads the newspaper anymore
I'm like how do you not
um I actually read the post one day and
I read The Daily News the next day and
the level like they were always
politicized but now it's like just
[__] unbelievable and I read this
hilarious article
that this dude had written
about how he came up with this idea
for a movie script
it was a good idea he wanted to do
he wanted to do a movie about
Roger I think it's Roger Bannister was
the first guy to run a sub
four minute mile he ran in the threes he
just barely made it 359 in change and it
was you know science said it was
impossible
so of course that becomes a goal and
there was these three guys trying to be
the first ones to do it and Roger
Bannister ended up doing it right it's a
great idea for a movie so he goes I
pitched the idea to this writer and he
just goes you know Hollywood's not going
to make it
right and he says well why not he goes
because it's about three white guys and
he goes all right what if I make one of
them black and the guy goes he's still
not going to make them so then he starts
to go on and on and on
about you know how this is all Holly
woke now and all this type of stuff and
I'm reading this article and I want to
be like buddy let me get this straight
you had an idea for a movie you pitched
it to one person and they said no
it's like that happens with every
[__] movie
okay I got a movie coming out called Old
dads I I I don't I couldn't even tell
you how many people we pitched it to and
they said no
and they just said no when they say no
and they say no until somebody says yes
and then you got to find money and then
you find that and then we made it and
then we didn't have anybody to
distribute it and then we were trying to
get it out in the theaters and then we
finally made a [__] deal and then
it's finally going to come out and I'm
not allowed to tell you this was like
[__] four years of my life
so
and it was just funny listening to a
white guy
bitching like acting like they're not
making white movies and it just really
made me think like I always thought it
was funny
how like when Hollywood
at these award shows has the nerve to
talk to Red States about race relations
when you see how far behind Hollywood is
like
Sports integrated like 60 [__] years
ago and I feel like Hollywood is is
where baseball was in like the 1950s and
they're patting themselves on the back
so then listen one of my fellow whities
my fellow white homeboys [__] getting
his panties in a bunch because he
pitched a [__] all-white movie to one
person and then he said no oh my God you
can't even get the movie made I just
want to be like dude this is how it is
this is what it's like to make a [__]
movie and relax movies are still 99
[__] white it's gonna be fine it's
gonna be okay pitch it to somebody else
keep pitching it it's a great [__]
idea for a movie I hope it gets made I'd
like to see it I find that fascinating I
didn't realize that there was three
people doing it but don't get involved
you know that was like you know I even
know when they started giving specials
out to other people and I would listen
to white male Comics going good I can't
even [__] get a special but it's like
yes you can
there's like [__] two percent
competition now and you're gonna fold up
the [__] tents you know it's good
competition is good this is all good
everybody's you know it's not a perfect
[__] thing
but don't [__] whine about it just
keep you know
everybody just keep pushing ahead I hope
that guy gets his movie made but he's
not going to get his movie made if he
pitches it to one person and they say
yeah that's not gonna happen and then
you [__] quit
I mean that goes back to everybody
people who had ideas for cars people had
this deals for business
you know you asking out some chick who
ended up being your wife she says no
like [__] nine times
you know you just you hang in there
I just thought it was such a bad message
to send to people that like you have an
idea
and you just try it once and when people
say no you just become that guy in a bar
going I'm trying to do it guys said no
and now I can't do it it's like what the
[__]
and then this person who wrote it is
very successful and there's no [__]
way he got there
and everybody said yes the whole way so
it's just one of those things where it's
just one of just one of those articles
where it's just like yeah this is a
great article why would you write this
could you are you just trying to divide
people
are you just trying to feed
like racist white people more ignorant
so there can be more [__] hate and
more divisive thing it's just such a
um I don't know
was depressing to read it you know what
I mean so anyway I hope that guy gets
the movie made because it seems like a
really good idea but I can tell you this
right now if he's just gonna pitch it to
one person and they're going to say no
and he's going to fold his tent he's
really writing an article on how not to
succeed in life so all you people out
there regardless of what color you are
whatever you want to do when you run it
by the first person and then they say no
just let it roll off your back all right
hey everybody it's water under the
fridge
hang in there you'll get there all right
and with that that's the podcast for
this week I know it's a little bit short
but I got to get packed here and I got
to get home to the family the family
back wished all right that's it uh go
[__] yourselves and I'll check in on you
on Thursday